ça va pas trop le trac pour la première
ça c'est sûr quand je dis ça fait dix
ans que sur les plateaux il ya un truc
infaillible pour ça l'invité tu y
rentres dedans
millon tulle et rentrent dedans djamel
tulle et rentrent dedans quel que soit
l'invité tu rentres dedans tu rentres
dedans tueur de hockey où j'ai bossé
jean la halle du hard pourquoi c'est bon
et si j'ai besoin de rien je t'appelle
[Musique]
alors t'as vu ce qui se passe là tout le
monde aux coutumes par l'intérêt que de
quoi la radio ou à la télé les journaux
tout le monde enfin à l'autre mais oui
ce matin chez léo précis m'attends à
tout moment pas à l'offre s'est foutu
c'est que j'ai eu trois quarts en ligne
la facture orientale est aussi mieux si
on parle oui lui aussi passifs ils en
parlent ça veut dire que tout le monde
encore hier à midi
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle vous connaissez le
principe tout le monde en parle
alors tout le monde en parle
vous connaissez l'équipe - si l'on
inquiet
mais ça c'est richie fay réussi cette
opération de chirurgie esthétique je
voudrais remercier et féliciter le
chirurgien le professeur championnat de
la clinique azoulay à un pardon à
casablanca non c'est bon ça
et voilà messieurs
ça va bien
j'accueille maintenant le phénomène le
plus fort dans le monde du comics depuis
coluche jamel debbouze ici
[Applaudissements]
et si nous sommes ici ça va très bien
oui mais c'est jean moulin c'est alors
si vous les trucs modicom in a truck
passé si tu vas à tu vas voir tu vas
dire quand même à toutes les
téléspectatrices qu'edel est plus beau
en vrai qu'à la télé moi j'avais
toujours voilà donc est à une ouverture
là et merde quoi encore une
tu savais pas j'avais la cote avec toi
merci beaucoup en tout cas de ce couple
et moi ça me pousse à partir mais je
revends ce soir charles millon axelle
red
patrick sabatier
christina o
[Applaudissements]
à l'été vous savez une tradition à la
télé quand on commence une nouvelle
édition c'est grave c'est une grande
famille on reçoit les télégrammes alors
c'est un télégramme de le premier de
christophe dechavanne thierrée bonne
chance merci custom un télégramme de
paco rabanne chéri linde ag prévoit la
fin de cette émission pour le 11
septembre et croyez moi je me plante
rarement laurent ruquier le vrai laurent
ruquier qui m'écrit bas il dit thierry
sincèrement désolés de ne pas faire un
an de plus mais j'avais trop envie de
faire un an de plus toujours égal à
lui-même bras volant
rocco siffredi désolé d'être là pour la
reprise thierry mais j'ai la tête dans
le cul et la maman de notre ami qui dit
monsieur ardisson serait-il possible de
faire un gros plan de mon fils serge
s'te plaît fait un gros plan de son fils
est là que je voulais juste
un message personnel à faire passer je
voulais juste souhaiter un bon
anniversaire à ma soeur valérie très
bien puisqu'on avait un message
personnel mais je voudrais dire bonsoir
à la famille vidéo qui regarde et que
j'embrasse vous avez un message
personnel d'une date ont cogné je fais
un gros bisou papa mamadou bah voilà et
mon frère sylvain jeu mais là elle a
deux hommes dans sa vie c'est son frère
et son père de personne n'est parfait
voilà donc tout ça pour dire que si
quelqu'un se sent le courage
oui elle est formidable c'est le regard
des badauds commençaient pour un
télégramme pour vous linda un télégramme
de sophie thalmann miss france elle
aussi un qui dit charles linda comment
tu as fait pour entrer à la télé sans
coucher un jeu ça j'ai couché
il n'en parlera pas mettre un télégramme
de jacques martin que nous le saluerons
méfie-toi de michel drucker d'accord un
télégramme de lara fabian je t'aime je
t'aime je t'aime je t'aime je t'aime je
t'aime merci merci la rate et g de smaïn
qui déchire thierry merci encore de
faire de la pub pour jamel sympa djamel
j'ai vu que vous êtes intéressé aux
samplers voulait venir voir ce que ça
tombe bien expliquer à tous d'avoir
exemple je viens même exemple imaginons
que je dise une grosse connerie
alors y'a michèle cotta qui dix
appareils ont tiré au fond tu aimes bien
relaté visage et voilà ça c'est la
patronne
par exemple si tu raconte que vous
racontez vous dit pas la vérité
ouais je cite si thierry à draguer une
fille comme ça lui arrive assez souvent
[Musique]
c'est pour vous ça va mieux je le
prenais le nouveau jouet lice hier si
j'ai bien compris si c'est pour c'est
pour combler le vide enfin c'est pas aux
meublés et quand tu galères un peu jeudi
par exemple les sources et ça risque de
donner ces têtes de donner ça
françois quentin les bassa si vous
regardez là s'était rompu la deuxième
nouveauté de la saison donc jamais elle
vous êtes aperçu c'est linda vous pouvez
jouer avec le sampler et j'ai eu un
déclic
y'a pas de problème d'accords devient si
tout se passe bien alors djamel donc
vous êtes au bataclan à partir du 15
septembre
est ce que c'est le même spectacle et
récits galles on a repris la base du
premier spectacle qui nous paraissait
pas inintéressante actuellement de
succès on a retravaillé autour et on a
trouvé des choses un peu fait des tours
il ya des nouvelles choses bien sûr
j'aurais pu répondre par oui j'ai fait
une question c'est bien mais ça fait
traiter les lapereaux l'interview vous
aimez les chiens jamais joué dans les
chiens très bien alors le sait le même
metteur en scène ben oui kader aoun vous
pensez durer jusqu'à noël
si tout se passe bien c'est déjà plus
court si tout se passe bien jusqu'à noël
ouais si linda viens pour me soutenir
dar salam sall alors djamel on s'est
connu tous les deux il ya quand même
quelques années maintenant 35 ans d'une
lente cinq ans bien sûr une émission que
je faisais à l'époque sur sur paris
dernière sur paris première il disparaît
dernière tu as fait un numéro qui était
bien d'ailleurs je crois que c'est votre
deuxième télé la première citée pêche
d'enfer c'était la vraie richesse et un
truc comme ça c'était une petite île et
tous les barbus et édition de plus non
si vous avez les images se voit bien
pourquoi c'est pas bien vous avez
toujours à la télé on invite des gens
leur montre des images qui les met mal à
l'aise
ces archives te plaît magnéto
ça
m
si c'est un succès je m'arrêter par marc
mahy là je suis à ce titre tu me prends
la tête
joris tous les petites manières izard et
oui il arrête là avec leurs oeufs
leur technique leur marathon haussler
bricole leurs questions c'est la fin
j'ai croisé un journaliste avec blizzard
ti-jean re6 genre sournois toi genre si
j'en ressors bizarrement genre théorie
son genre comme l'appareil
ces prix-là récit commence à me poser
des questions sur le toit était si petit
jeu type bizarre et j'y mets partout et
immeubles étaient bien d'habitude moi je
vais pas je vais traiter at il été
choisi comme ça comme celle là il a fait
comme ça écoute bon moi aussi je suis
capable je suis la banlieue comme vous
ainsi battant mère m'a écouté j'espère
que tu vois je vais d'autobus en coton
la question je vais vous parler en toute
franchise de vos problèmes économiques
sociaux culturels car je sais c'est pas
la peine de me dire que vous avez
d'énormes problèmes vous insérez parmi
les gens normaux
je sais que votre père tapotement que
vous avez traduit à vous servir de
crédit comme moyen de locomotion
il se trouve que c'est pas vrai j'ai des
preuves si ça marche aussi grave j'étais
binaire grave commune à tous sauf grave
tout à l'heure j'ai regardé jeudi
l'autre brontosaure à l'autre
brontosaure d'abord d'options vous voit
on n'a jamais vraiment jamais vous les
décalant sans que je sache
d'accord un donc tu vois d'abord dieu je
vous dis je me demande quelle est celle
où les deux qu'elle puisse de mal à ça
c'est réparé mais j'ai rarement à à moi
avec mes caddie ou lui avec sa pub sur
la tête là nous deux c'est pas mon père
qui tape ma mère c'est ma mère car mon
père dernière
c'était c'était quand j'étais en cm2 ça
ouais ouais c'était que c'était très
très longtemps
je me souviens de cet exercice non
sérieusement ça vous embête non pas du
tout la télé moi où je me regarde pas
j'ai toujours un peu de critiques sur ce
que je fais je fais les choses et
souvent je ne trouve pas bien après et
là je trouve ça à propos du tout bon
john est là ce qu'on vient de voir donc
c'était la deuxième était d après ap à
raconter votre carrière parce qu'elle a
été racontée en long et en large et une
ovalie paris première une autre émission
qui étaient les missions de nova sur
paris première il ya eu il ya eu h
lpa le cinéma avec son 11e et puis le
ciel les oiseaux et ta mère qui fait
quand même dix mille 1 million par an 10
millions d'un million 10 millions
d'indiens
il ya millions de millions mais mnp à
canal+ c'est c1 halabi un alibi pour
vous celle inverse c'est défendre j'ai
vu dans les interviews on vous demandait
souvent est ce que vous pensez pas être
l'alibi de canal+ moi j'ai plutôt
l'impression que finalement c'est canal+
que votre alibi pour regrouper des
florentins regarder canal plus
uniquement et simplement pour l'argent
faut pas l'oublier et les meufs et celle
d'argent ça a marché
non mais mes sous pour reprendre pour
rapport atteint de plus sérieux on m'a
souvent posé la question je ne trouve
pas que tu es là tu es là tu es le quota
de canal + se prête à un robot de canal+
je pense vraiment pas je pense que la
main de greef m'a engagé parce qu'il
croyait en moi j'espère enfin je suis
sûr mais puisque je le dis comme ça mais
c'est un échange de bons procédés
finalement oui de toute manière comme
dans toute association qui fonctionne
bien tu vois gj gagner et aussi mais
c'est sûr qu'au début on pouvait se
poser la question
et enfin continent et enfin de jeu
ça veut dire à chaque fois qu'il va
pêcher un bouton vous allez me dire
comme des imbéciles
j'ai compris le système deviendra une
punition aussi dans le sampler si par
exemple j'étais un truc vraiment ou moi
ou linda dit un truc vraiment pénible à
la punition mesdames messieurs
il faut faire attention à ce qu'on dit
c'est imovie ni voilà moi je vais pas
intérieure en corse parce que tu vois
non mais mais mais alors chaque fois que
je dirais une connerie ira ça ira ça
ouais et quand tu es quand tu dis un
truc génial au rsa bon alors la gloire
vous parlez beaucoup de votes loire la
mercedes tapis rouge aux bains douches
etc et j'en parle pas moi sans les gens
nous ont fait part les oui oui mais vous
avez quand même il ya un truc plus
intéressant si vous avez quand même une
méfiance paris vous appelez ça le côté
obscur c'est quand même une méfiance de
paris 1 le coche et essaie mais c'est
vrai j'y habite à trappes dans les
yvelines et on débarque dans un dans une
jungle véritablement je suis pas là à
faire tu sais très bien comment ça se
passe si harry fait pas ton petit malin
mais je sais mais mais mais ouais j'ai
tout était inaccessible et d'un coup
tout s'ouvre donc forcément tu te mets
fini tu prenais la distance avec les
filles ça se passe bien maintenant un
peu mieux
un peu mieux mais je galère encore
vraiment c'est vrai
la liste
ça tombe bien parce que sinon j'ai passé
la soirée avec sa mère
si aujourd'hui une fille une jeune femme
que vous avez draguer ya cinq ans et qui
vous avait chuté drague à son tour
aujourd'hui je la jette plus aucun
intérêt non non faut passer maintenant
je passe à autre chose maintenant
maintenant ccc linda que je suis là il
ya quelque chose qu'il ya une souris
pendant ta question oui effectivement
les filles intéressées
non mais je sais pas si je détecte les
filles intéressées moi je suis
sincèrement je suis très naïve de ce
côté là je ne prends pas encore détecté
quoi que ce soit mais qu'elle
s'intéresse à moi je fonce occupent les
moines à la blague à part mais j'ai aimé
c'est vrai que que non non j'ai pas
j'avais toujours à trappes j'ai pas
bougé je rencontre les filles avec qui
j'avais quand même moins en moins
souvent à traves habitants temps là bas
j'y vais tous les soirs à demain soir et
celui non plus tard pour porter oui
forcément
alors il ya une phrase moi de vous de
germaine que je trouve très très bien
c'est quand vous parlez de paris vous
dites c'est comme dans le film quand
charlton heston descend du mont sinaï où
il a reçu les dix commandements on vous
dit à moïse l'abri de charlton heston
comme ce qui est très symbolique quand
il a reçu les dix commandements il
descend comme ça du il descend du sinaï
voit tous les hébreux en train d'adorer
le veau d'or et ça c'est un peu l'image
que vous faites de paris finalement ben
ouais parce que
c'est sincèrement j'arrive là depuis
deux trois ans dans un univers que je
connaissais pas c'est à dire on choisir
de calais matin midi soir de toutes les
voix qui vous toutes les boîtes que j'ai
fait sans exception sans exception je me
dis je me faisais recalé en bloc tout
papa toutes les filles sans exception
mais on avait du mal avec les filles
aussi pareil on n'avait pas l'argent
qu'il fallait pour avoir les sabres
qu'il fallait on n'était pas dans le
coup donc ont été mis à l'écart et est
maintenant d'un coup tout le monde
s'intéresse à moi et toute notre
attention à ce que je dis c'est
formidable alors jamais on va maintenant
finir un petit peu cette parce qu'après
on va passer une vrai interview on va
finir un peu avec un extrait moi qui m'a
beaucoup plu c'est quand vous étiez à
cannes c'est d'ailleurs comme l'émission
paris dernière réalisée par sylvain
bergère c'est le journal de la nuit et
on vous voit face à face avec le plus
grand comique français langer à magnéto
serge s'il te plaît ils ont un super
bowl
bannon sa propriété il y avait david est
un design des plus grandes et plus ou
moins du monde
enfin ben non si si si sur canal + je
trouve ça drôle
effectivement on a va être parfait
la puce si bien dit mais qu'est ce qui
montre à ce que j'ai c'est qu'on peut
pas bouffer sans qu'une caméra à les
autres accords le cadre est sûre avec un
décor à denis bouffard de notation de
gêne à l'idée au parlement face à
ouais enfin de repasser l'eau parmi on
doit se demander s'ils n'agissent la
dire que vider le lac l'un des mecs les
plus drôles de france voilà ça c'est
vrai
c'est de la chanson but est souvent bien
accompagné il dit dans des endroits sont
que la casse mais après tout le monde
circule watts est l'homme le plus drôle
de france
on enchaîne sur un pieu alors donc vous
avez comme je disais tout à l'heure vous
avez beaucoup raconté votre légende vous
avez un discours très au point
d'ailleurs quand on voit à la télé ou
quand on voit son livre déclarations
dans la presse discours très au point ce
n'est pas ce qu'on pose tout le temps
les mêmes cas là c'est justement ce
qu'on veut pas ce que vous dites que
vous avez un personnage très très
construit vous dit évidemment mon
personnage est construite toute pièce
parce que si j'étais comme lui j'aurai
une chambre à sainte anne depuis depuis
longtemps bien évidemment bien
évidemment alors à vous poser des
questions qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de
vous poser la télé à ça ça fait plaisir
par contre voilà sp c'est un peu la
lumière
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'aime pas les traquenards comme ça pose
est est-ce que je peux avoir un canif
watts en suisse un couteau suisse est
possible ou pas à régis bande d'enfoirés
vous êtes tous avec lui dans l'éducation
simple à vous pensez à quoi là
maintenant là tout de suite tout de
suite c'est non mais franchement un nom
assez vulgairement parole non mais tu
non mais c'est bon on peut se lâcher un
peu plus nos lèvres
non non je te jure bon bah je rigole
tout de suite là comme ça je me demande
ce que tu as posé comme pression bon ben
voilà donc qu'est ce que tu penses le
matin quand tu dois dans la glace quand
tu te réveilles la première chose que tu
te dis quant à vous vous dites pardon je
me dis [ __ ] si je faisais dix
centimètres de plus je serai mannequin
déjà vu cette fois impossible il faut
dix centimètres de plus proche ric-rac
dans le sel quand vous étiez petit
voulait ressembler à qui quand j'étais
petit je voulais ressembler à tony
montana dans scarface 1 s'est excusé moi
ça vu le film scarface
ouais bien sûr je vous laisse y comme
plein de mecs dans le quartier ski c'est
ce qui vous énerve le plus chez vous ce
que je supportais pas assez difficile
icd essayons de répondre à cette
question
bah ouais mon manque de
de subjectivité je pense ouais j'aime
pas ma subjectivité
sauf qu'elle est pas assez adéquat que
des mots compliqués la subjectivité
année la reine j'avais du cabinet est-ce
que vous supportez pas chez moi
qu'est-ce que vous supportez pas chez
moi tiens toi pourquoi tu t'habilles
tout en noir pour être sûr qu'on me
reconnaisse
non non c'est pas pour ça m'arrive de me
dire si on sait que mentir c'est
pourquoi pas en tire comme ça ce que ça
marche c'est parce que celle ci s'est
amincie ouais ouais ça fait un gros là
bas non non non non vous faites du sport
depuis quelques temps ben j'ai un côté
sa main le noir c'est un mât simba le
noir serna sur notre chéri chéri dalle
qu'est-ce que vous supportez pas chez
linda ouais j'ai vraiment pour l'instant
rien du tout je supporte tout pour le
moment
et quand venir quand vous êtes vous
senti le maître du monde est ce qu'un
jour vous avez le sentiment d'être
vraiment un demi-dieu de en toute
modestie jamais ouais non non je te jure
j'ai jamais et aujourd'hui est ce que il
ya quelque chose que vous soyez à avoir
absolument que voudriez par dessus tout
vous ne pouvez pas acheter qui vous
tenterait ou qui vous ferait extrêmement
plaisir et que vous pouvez pas posséder
la suite comme ça mais mise à part toi
je vois pas
je cherche mais non non quelle insulte
qui vous a fait le plus mal en fait dans
votre vie espèce de sale arabe
ouais enfin que m'a fait plus mal c'est
des trucs tu supportes pas du tout que
j'entende de moins en moins maintenant
mais mesure mais mais mais c'est
vraiment il part aux lois entendre et
quand vous écrivez eu l'autographe vous
écrivez ça dépend si c'est des filles ou
des garçons est déjà si c'est une fille
de marc gros bisous jamais de nous y
fait un coeur si c'est un garçon je
marque que dégage de mousse à dégage est
ce que vous êtes déjà sortie avec la
copine pour voir si vous avez un peu de
moral quand même oui tu veux tu écris
dans le plat c'est d'actualité merde
merde
non pas du tout jamais je suis avec le
copain ou une copine avec le copain du
copain dont claudine non encore moins
bon si par exemple vous trouvez un porte
monnaie que 500 francs dedans par terre
vous faites quoi
j'ai maintenant je leur en avons voulu
garder ouais c'est bien c'est honnête
comme à nos jours moi je laurent parce
que je pense à la pauvre vieille qui
nous ont prêté en turquie et je trouve
et s'était hissé tgt j'avais pas encore
autant d'argent qu'aujourd'hui et je
trouve un portefeuille mais super blindé
d'argent plein et épais tousser et
c'était une demoiselle qui étaient là
qui est qui qui travaillait dans l'hôtel
où j'étais j'ai elle va elle vendait des
pellicules je me rappelle je prends le
portage il jure en jurant pages durant
en jurant pareil je rentre je rends pas
jure en jurant pas j'y allais à les
juges en jeu lurgi vga et je fais la clé
pour lui rendre ce fait la queue pour
lui rendre est un moment donné je te
jure juge alors j'arrive gérant le
portefeuille
et puis je lui dit excusez moi je
pourrais avoir cette pellicule mais je
veux faire la gueule du monde
je regarde comme s'agit mais pourquoi
par dell de mer jours en russie de colas
là déjà ça m'a énervé est ce que vous
seriez prêt à tout quitter pour le grand
amour ça ça se discute
salut la france a c'est parce que je
peux rien faire d'autre moitié je peux
paraître me pombieilh mécanicien je peux
pas me lever à 8 heures du matin et
finir à 17 heures mais pour elle
peut-être à si vraiment c'est le grand
amour alan grant amour grand amour je
lâche tout donc le grand amour n'est pas
encore arrivé
j'avais le héros un euro c'est jamal un
héros est ce que si vous étiez ruiné
plus du tout d'argent enfin vraiment peu
une étude est ce que vous seriez prêt à
tourner dans un film porno aucune chance
à toi un truc très simple jamais je
serai je serai ruine et j'ai tiré j'ai
une famille assez solidaires et avec il
ya un problème ils sont là je serai
jamais obligé je suis un mais je pense
est-ce que vous préféreriez faire
l'amour avec une fille très laide ou un
mec très beau produit quelques questions
mais que ouais c'est ça faut pas arrêter
comment ces questions alors c'est toi
qui écris les questions comme les
saisons le contrôle des questions comme
toi si tu veux les faux-pas faut prendre
dit doliprane parce qu'il ya eu la
douleur constante et la douleur d'avoir
fait pour toi maman c'est bien ça stoppe
la douleur des critiques et tu préfère
faire l'impasse on sait où
l'homosexualité ou une fille très nets
par an soit une ville très laide ou un
mec très beau vous choisiriez quoi
j'irai plus vers la savonnette mois et
entre une miss monde les trois miss
france ou poêlée quoi je mange je prends
trois miss france 3 miss france est
gentil pour les 10 à 20 points 3 miss
france si vous aviez 24 heures avis vous
feriez quoi on vous dit vous allez
mourir dans 24 heures foyer quoi sur j
eelv et auprès fleur bleue tout ce que
tu veux mais c'est la vérité je vais
auprès de maman ouais je reste avec l 24
heures ils attendent comme ça j'ai déjà
cinq ans âge où j'ai voulu monter jamais
à votre maman non pour l'une des rares
personnes à qui je mens pas pourquoi
parce que le sait tout de suite quand je
vois pas ce que je fais des petits quand
je mangeais à chaque ligne un peu
maintenant je dois je vais y travailler
ah ouais vous de ma gueule alors y'a un
truc chez vous qui étiez très justement
parce que aujourd'hui dans l'est la télé
à la radio les gens osent plus dire
qu'ils sont croyants catholiques c'est
un peu passé de mode c'est un peu
ringard j'ai des gens comme vous et
c'est des gens comme vous qui osez dire
finalement beaucoup plus que les
catholiques
ben moi je suis musulman je suis croyant
évidemment je fais un petit peu d c'est
c'est d'autant plus difficile qu'en ce
moment on n'a pas trop la cote de ce
côté là les intégristes ne font pas une
super bonne publicité non plus hein nous
non plus les cathos les intégrés s'ils
ne font pas une bonne bruit mais mais
mais mais on parlera plus de nous que
vous en ce moment mais c'est vrai que
non j'ai aucun problème avec ça j'ai été
baigné là dedans mes parents - moins
élevé avec avec ses traditions là je
suis musulman je l'assumé mais c'est un
truc que je vais très bien parce que
l'islam est une religion qui
quitteraient très tolérant très ouverte
et et je la kiffe je trouve que c'est
très c'est là c'est la classe des
musulmans est ce que vous buvez pas vous
fumez pas d'enjeu boit pas elle fume pas
sérieux vous pratiquez les cinq prières
par jour par exemple j'essaye du mieux
que je peux mais comme je rentre tard
des fois c'est maintenant c'était quand
la dernière la ct garage était le mois
de novembre dernier un vrai dans leurs
prières dans la lah c'était ce matin à
huy donc 5
c'était entre 8 et 9,9 et 5,1 ce matin
je me suis levé et est 10 heures et tu
cèdes à des heures précises avec les
faussaires et la demande la dernière à
la dernière c'était ce matin alors j'en
ai encore quatre à rattraper d'être très
vif être réincarné en quoi moi ouais
j'suis embourbé à non non non non si je
devrais être en interne dans quelque
chose ce sera endigué par un guépard
c'est bien de départ c'est bien s'il
avec la classe le guépard dans la savane
fond il est bien habillé le guépard il
ya des beaux habits est-ce que vous avez
menti depuis le début de cette émission
non franchement devant papa dépend de ce
jour là encore c'est bien je suis ravie
mercier c'était le gars des vues
[Applaudissements]
alors avant avant de passer à notre
invitation mais bien entendu vous restez
avec nous je voudrais pardon vous lisez
ça moi je voulais dire que je suis
agréablement surpris par ce genre de
question parce que je suis pas
l'habitude comme les pauses mais voilà
c'est bien thierry cain d'éclaircies
alors alors avant de poster un mec bien
je me comprends avant de passer à notre
invité suivant bien entendu bien sûr
djamel vous restez avec nous dès l'année
suivante
charles millon jana je me bats on va
regarder on va regarder le real c'est
facile on m'appelle monsieur discutera
revient en tâtant oui il arrive
mais avant avant charles millon je
voudrais quand on regarde un extrait du
spectacle jamel en scène donc à la
cigale et qu'on va retrouver à partir du
15 septembre au bataclan
magnéto serge n'ont dit si bien qu'ils
aient pas mûres à reste quand même
maintenant
arrêtez de pleurer avec les peuples et
gargamel
pardon mais discutait on peut discuter
quand même c'est pas toi tu jettes
enchanté ne sait pas chanter cette
chanson ce avant lundi matin
lebrun sa mère sont venus chez moi pour
qu'elles portent des reins petits trucs
comme je n'étais pas chez moi le petit
prince a dit habashi lui et c'est pas
grave tout mais je veux en venir
plus lourde 20 du rendement mardi matin
que classe sa mère le prince et puis sa
mère
sont venus chez moi pour qu'on va perdre
a foutu comme j'étais déjà en train de
faire un foot
les petits princes a dit abonnés qui
gère inclure un footeux c'est pas grave
encore du mangement vidéo dure de 3
heures du mans va battre du matin le
prince sa mère sa tante avec connais pas
et puis à l'autre mecs sont venus chez
moi pour que je leur rende leur âge on
m'avait prêté et comme je vais gaspiller
tout l'argent qu'ils avaient prêté le
petit prince a dit avant d'expliquer aux
gens de me prêter
ce revers de main je lâche pas la peine
[Applaudissements]
jamais de wade à partir les 15 septembre
au matin quand ça leur chante cigale
c'était bon répertoire
ouais hein abdullah comme on dit chez
moi c'était des flammes mais mais mais
le bataclan ccc internautes paris il ya
beaucoup plus ce soir quatre mois et on
attend 80 mille personnes ah ouais donc
je vous en supplie venez non mais on
sera là non sera parmi les 80 merci très
bien j'accueille maintenant notre asile
assurances jamais le dos et c'est avec
tout charles millon
[Musique]
au lion bonsoir bonsoir connaissait
djamel vous connaissez mardi bonsoir
charles millon champmillon merci d'être
avec nous est ce que c'est vrai que
c'est une émission je dis pas difficile
parce qu on est vachement sympa mais
enfin c'est vrai que c'est une émission
où là où la liberté de ton et peut-être
un peu plus grande qu'ailleurs
alors jean mimi on va faire un petit un
petit comment du rex était pratiqué
latif ouais ça c'est bien ça donc il
yal'affaire millions on va en parler
puis après on parlera de l'avenir on va
pas rester scotchés là dessus tout la
soirée
vous étiez un homme politique disons
centre-droit plutôt fréquentable vous
avez été ministre de la défense entre 95
et 97 sous chirac bien entendu vous
étiez prodi solution assez ça vous étiez
pour la dissolution de l'assemblée
nationale
oui avec changement de premier ministre
avec changement de premier ministre et
le 20 mars 1998 vous êtes élu président
de la région rhône alpes avec les voix
des conseillers du front national
d'ailleurs il ya eu un moment il ya eu
un fameux vendredi a eu un moment où
tout a failli basculer
c'est effectivement le jour où beaucoup
de régions en france beaucoup de
présidents de région ont été élus avec
les voix du front national et madelin a
dit d'ailleurs en parlant de ce fameux
vendredi plus rien ne sera jamais comme
avant
et puis on peut penser que jean marie le
pen en exigeant la présidence de paca a
fait échouer la faire on peut se
demander s'il était pas lié comme on l'a
dit souvent l'allié objectif disons de
la gauche donc vous vous avez été à
partir de là entre guillemets
le président élu grâce au fn donc ça
vous est resté comme ça collait je
disais j'avais un jet à un projet
politique j'ai présenté mon projet
politique
il ya un certain nombre de voix qui se
sont portées sur ce projet c'est pas
parce que les bois viennent d'ici ou de
là qu'on va en fait remettre en cause le
projet qui avait obtenu le soutien de la
majorité des rhônalpins j'avais
lorsqu'un communiste dit le soleil
brille que effectivement le soleil
brille ce n'est pas parce que je suis
pas d'accord avec lui que je veux dire
qu'il pleut lorsque quelqu'un du front
national dit il pleut et que
effectivement il pleut c'est pas parce
qu'il est du front national que je vais
dire qu'il fait beau dit quand on est
élu on est élu peu importe vous d'où
vient d'où viennent les voies alors
même temps c'était pas seulement un
hasard c'est une stratégie parce que
vous êtes le front national est légal
l'état de chaque année 41 millions de
francs au front national
donc c'est un parti légal y'a pas de
raison s'il est légal et qu'on ne
s'associe pas avec lui votre après tout
françois mitterrand avait bien fait la
même chose avec le pcf dans l'union de
la gauche ce que vous vouliez votre
stratégie c'était de briser le tabou et
c'était ça c'était de sortir sortir de
la tenaille et vous avez dit à l'époque
si j'arrive à intégrer le front national
dans la vie politique française
j'aurais rendu un fier service à la
france c'est à tout instant c'était
voulu
je n'aime pas du tout ce n'est pas tout
à fait cela que j'ai dit j'ai dit la
chose suivante
[Musique]
jeudi la chose suivante il ya deux
méthodes de faire la politique soit vous
la faites après vous êtes fait élire
alors besoin des alliances avec untel ou
untel c'est à dire que vous faites votre
petite cuisine dans votre petit but
votre petite casserole sur le petit
fourneau dans votre petit coin c'est ce
que l'expression du général de gaulle ou
alors vous avez une autre solution si de
vous présenter un projet quand les gens
à adopter ce projet bien vous le mettez
en oeuvre la première solution c'est une
solution tromperie et la deuxième
solution serait une solution de clarté
donc voila voila j'ai un petit peu
brossé le tableau l'histoire
l'historique de la faire parce que tout
le monde n'a pas ça obligatoirement
toujours en tête
moi j'ai une question à vous poser en
fait est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous pensez
que vous avez fait une boulette une
grosse connerie ou est ce que vous le
regrettez donc en l'occurrence ou est-ce
que vous pensez que vous aviez raison
voilà c'est la seule question finalement
enfin pas la seule mais c'est la
question principale que j'ai envie de
vous poser la cuillère sur le bouton
puis vous mettez je ne regrette rien a
en la page en rabattant on a pas on est
désolé mais vous avez pas répondu à ma
question je ne regrette rien donc vous
ne regrettez pas du tout vous dites soit
aujourd'hui j'ai fait une erreur
j'aurais pas dû faire ça comme ça parce
que c'est on peut faire des erreurs
marketing et au regard de la smart c'est
une erreur un petit soupçon regrets rien
du tout alors je ne reviens tu reviens
je suis j'avais arrêté quelque chose
j'aurais démissionné
on ne s'était pas une connerie je
regrette pas j'assume ce que j'ai fait
très bien mais dès le début quand même
et pas seulement la gauche puisque
chirac vous a dit il a téléphoné pour
vous dire charles taffs une conne chirac
il dissertait sur votre portable et qui
lui dit qu'il est dit charlotte a fait
une connerie
raymond barre qui a toujours été votre
mentor en politique dans la région
n'étaient pas solidaires d'eux
donc je dirai ce que je veux dire
charles millon c'est qu'ils avaient pas
seulement la gauche et qui qui qui
étaient contre ça avait aussi des gens
de votre de votre bord des gens de la
droite n'ont sorti comme d'autres gens
c'est ce qu'on appelle le politiquement
correct c'est à dire que personne je
pose des questions il met dans le vent
des apprentis c'est de ma faute alors
l'adjoint au maire non je rigole charles
[Applaudissements]
ce qu'on appelle le politiquement
correct c'est à dire que vous avez un
certain nombre des personnages
politiques quel que soit le poste qu'ils
occupent qui n'osent pas aller contre
des tabous une pensée conforme à partir
de là vous avez été diabolisé ostracisé
vous êtes devenu un peu le paria de la
classe politique et des moments
difficiles qui a été le moment le plus
difficile ce que le monument à la
mémoire des enfants juifs à lisieux où
on vous a interdit de nous approcher
tout à fait sans doute le moment
l'enquêté le plus émouvant est le plus
triste parce que j'ai consacré une bonne
part de ma vie à cette cause de ma vie
politique je me suis investi oui je suis
très triste et si vous avez créé ce
parti qui s'appelle la droite de la
droite c'est quand même qu'en france
c'est un gros mot depuis quarante-quatre
la droite j en entends 44 depuis 1789
puisque vous n'avez la droite tu dis à
quelqu'un a dit madiba de fer droite et
non mais je sais pas quand on dit la
droite en france on les gens entendent
tout de suite vichysme voir nazisme
enfin la droite depuis quarante gares
depuis la droite a perdu la guerre on
pourrait dire même des gens 47 quand
encore deux golfeuses et de l'affichage
pour son parti qui s'appelait le rpf à
l'époque déjà il y avait des gens qu'ils
aient des croix gammées sur les affiches
de ne vole donc je vais dire la droite
c'est la provocation d'appeler à partie
la droite la droite c'est complexe et
elle n'a pas voulu porter les valeurs
auxquelles elle croit que sont les
valeurs de liberté d'autonomie de
responsabilité d'initiative des valeurs
telles que les valeurs familiales ou les
valeurs entrepreneuriales
lc complexé pas ce qu'on lui disait si
tu te dit de droite tu es un pétainiste
tu as fasciste je ne suis ni pessimiste
ni fasciste je suis de droite
je suis fidèle à des valeurs auxquelles
les gens tiennent cois lorsque mots je
vais dans ma circonscription les gens
tout cela parce que je respecte ceux qui
sont à gauche voulait dire et bien là il
faut que la droite n'ont pas trop
justement
vrai on en parlera tout s'avère
d'ailleurs la casse c'est pas avec
quelqu'un qui va venir nous voir mais
c'est vrai que vous n'avez pas envie d
une grande conscience politique parce
que j'y parle plutôt du nutella est pas
restée là mais il ya quand même quelque
chose derrière tes conneries merde il
faut le salir
et quand je dis quand je dis je je je ne
suis pas la politique c'est parce que il
m'intéresse pas séparés provoque je dis
ça mais j'ai jamais connue depuis que je
suis en âge de comprendre un homme
politique qui a tenu ses engagements
jusqu'au bout et qui m'a prouvé que ce
qu'ils disaient c'était vrai que il
pourrait changer les choses
on a pensé quoi que gmail quand par
exemple sur le million et contre le vote
des immigrés trouve ça regrettable pour
tout l'été comme quand il est pour la
peine de mort ou comme quand il est peu
contre l'avortement ou continuer pour le
pacs trouve ça dommage ce genre de
choses mais chacun sa vie en accord avec
la politique c'est le débat oui c'est
bien mais qu'est ce que j'ai dit j'ai
dit le contraire j'ai juste dit que
imposa questions j'y réponds que je veux
ça regrettable mais je suis content
quand on peut débattre d'un certain
nombre vous n'êtes pas véritablement et
pour je suis pas pour la peine de mort
je j'ai voté contre l'abolition de la
peine de mort parce qu'à l'époque il n'y
avait pas de peines de substitution
je dis qu'aujourd'hui d'ailleurs le
problème est toujours posée parce qu'on
fermait quelqu'un pour 18 ans pour 20
ans ou même au delà c'est l'enfermer
dans l'enfer et donc il faut que tu le
savais non c'est pas du tout parce que
ça aurait pu tuer ça sert à rien déjà il
a galéré spécial pour moi
non non on prend il faut le mettre à
leur criaient d'autres je pense qu'il ya
une réflexion à mener en matière
pénitentiaire pour savoir s'il n'est pas
meilleur de l'isoler dans un cadre vous
vous dites faut que tu m'aies dirais
quand j'ai pas du tout si vous avez dit
ça tout à l'aise jamais bail était
d'exiger des témoins son but j'entendais
mal ramé pour blague à part vous êtes
pour la peine de mort je ne suis pas
pour la peine de mort je suis pour une
antenne de substitution qui soit picam
qu'ils soient humaines
aujourd'hui la peine de substitution
konami elle est inhumaine
car enfermer quelqu'un dans une pièce de
4 mètres sur 4 durant dix-huit
maintenant 22 ans 25 ans le tipi devient
fou devient une loque et que dans ce cas
là il vaut peut-être mieux chercher
d'autres modes d'isolement social on
peut
v il a existé je vais vous dire un mot
qui va vous choquer puisqu'on fait une
émission puisque la rage si
politiquement incorrect on va y aller
mais l'extrême le bagne le bagne est
meilleur que la prison à vie
car au moins vous êtes vous pouvez avoir
une activité qu'on peut faire un bagne
moderne où les gens sont bannis parce
qu'on les met en dehors de la société
pourtant qu'il ne porte atteinte aux
autres qu'ils ne viennent pas qu'il ne
tue pas qu'ils n'atteignent pas la
liberté des autres
mais au moins on leur laisse une ère
d'expansion et de liberté et
d'épanouissement isoler la société et
que je pense que le grand problème c'est
que voyez je vais utiliser un mot je
suis sûr que demain on va dire charles
million et pour le bagne j'ai pas lu il
ya des chances dans tous les cas vous
voyez la force des mots parce que vous
souvenez que quand edouard balladur
avait dit on devrait discuter de la
préférence nationale qui existe dans un
tas de pays dans le monde
c'est un scandale et bien là la force
des mots tout à fait besoin pour vous
saviez ça que la gauche et l arbitre des
élégances en france même même alain
madelin aujourd'hui dit qu'il faut fumer
des pétards non mais l'allemagne y ait
des toxicomanes aussi
non vous avez vous allez au massacre et
mais je pense que les choses changent
ouais parce que le 17 heures avec la
boutique du pollen 10 00 c'est mort elle
n'a jamais bu jamais fumé de ma plume et
y injecter jamais tai chi j'ai jamais
joué et des deux labels de l'air non je
vais pas vous avez encore le temps je
viens et oui encore un peu tendre quoi
est-ce que ça je suis sûr vous avez fumé
de la brc pas pourquoi vous avez une
tête avoir fumé de labeur non
en conséquence mais bon ce soir
la part du lion
est ce que dans le dernier bouquin de
jean d'ormesson il fait état d'une
confidence que françois mitterrand lui
aurait faites concernant le lobby juif
est le fils de françois mitterrand on a
rajouté une couche encore plus épaisse
derrière est ce que vous vous croyez
qu'il ya un lobby juif en france
je pense que les groupes d'influencé est
évident il ya un groupe d'influents ce
juif et un groupe d'influencé catholique
et un groupe d'influents ce protestant
qu'il ya eu le groupe d' influence des
parents d'élèves le groupe d'influencé
industriels et que ça me paraît de toute
influence des amis de jamel debbouze de
trappes
ça me parait mais ça me paraît tout à
fait naturel et normal donc l'expression
le bee est une expression qui a en
france choc
on pensait déjà aux états unis il ya le
reconnut états unis l'été en france très
bien que ça évoque quand même des choses
qui sont pas très donc c'est pour ça que
je me paraîtrait plus intelligent et
plus judicieux d'utiliser le terme
groupe d'influents groupes d'influencé
l'écart est tout à fait normal alors
dernière chose puis je vous laisserai
dans les imprimés jamais ils répondent à
ce qu'on leur propose dessus comme ça
j'aurai mais j'ai fais pas pour vous
uniquement chargée pour le non mais
c'est vrai tu poses une question les
crédits alors oui excusez mon régulière
je vous explique ce n'est pas la
question qu'il faut poser exactement et
vos moutons savoir qui est le christ au
camp des ide oui non oui non 100
millions plus grave là maintenant vous
jouez un peu multi bon l'honnête
rustique provincial macha et et voilà
mais quand même et ça rejoint un petit
peu ce que vient de dire jamel en 1992
dans le point vous avez déclaré à
catherine pégard l' alliance avec le fn
est une collaboration dessus alors ça
c'est sa voix là là là là ça lui donne
je dirais ça donne raison au fait qu'il
y ait des hommes politiques comme ça
parce que vous dites en 92 alliance avec
le fn et une collaboration et puis en 98
finalement on accepte tout à fait votre
explication enfin vous gouverner la
région avec les voix du fn c'est pas une
collaboration ça ça rien à voir a
expliqué nous alors on est bien
comprendre on attend explique jeu tout
s'explique
on attend une alliance c'est quoi ces
deux personnes qui se mettent ensemble
qui se font des concessions les unes
les autres qui je te donne ça tu me
prends ça et qui après dix ans va gérer
ensemble
l'autre solution c'est une personne qui
arrive qui dit voilà quelles sont les
actions que vous engagez qui veut et
soutenir sans ce compromis sans
concession sans discussion je ne change
rien mon projet et à ce moment là il ya
une majorité qui dit ok je soutiens ce
projet dans le premier cas vous savez
des compromis et vous avez un
renoncement à vos valeurs dans le second
cas doit rester à bout fidèle à nos
valeurs et vous ne changez aller à votre
comportement plus avoue quand même temps
je méconnais pas aux politiques autant
je trouve c'est une excuse bidon voyager
ou en moins que le coup ensemble et là
on est qu on a vécu ça ou alors tu vois
je décide du coup et si tu te mets avec
moi donc ça veut dire que on s'allie
avec les gens qui se ressemble
s'assemble en même temps vous connaissez
ce dicton nom sali avec des personnes
qui ont les mêmes valeurs et convictions
que vous hri dans tout à l'heure la du
fn vous avez donc les mêmes valeurs et
répondit son nom je vous explique steve
rogers auront comme il ya deux solutions
wichita la première c'est la paper board
pas parce qu'on passe à lardy view serge
khalfon on peut baisser un petit peu la
lumière mines d'or et là messieurs alors
linda alors moi je veux vous poser
je vous interviewez d'une manière un peu
plus intime j'espère que vous allez vous
prêter au jeu donc d'abord on sait qu'en
général les hommes politiques sont grand
séducteur mais qui plaisent beaucoup aux
femmes
donc moi je voudrais savoir par exemple
qu'est-ce qui fait
aux yeux des femmes que vous charles
millon vous est a priori plus attirants
qu'un thierry ardisson cannes jamel qui
sont pas mal en fait
comment est ce que vous aimez non moi je
trouve la tête à la classe avec ta
cravate de toutes les couleurs comment
est ce que vous espériez ses succès
politiques le pouvoir attire les femmes
blancs secs le pouvoir à tient les
femmes le pouvoir accueillir tout le
monde et en particulier les femmes plus
quand le pouvoir les lumières l'argent
est ce qu ont séduit une femme comment
séduire l'auditoire
je crois oui c'est à dire le rapport
révèle que sont les mêmes noms le
rapport avec une seule elle rapports
avec une femme sont très très très
proche c'est à dire que lorsque vous
faites un discours non seulement on
voulait convaincre avec des arguments
mais vous essayez de convaincre aussi
avec des sentiments avec des oui c'est
la passion quoi qu'il en soit que c'est
à dire la pression de son métier quand
vous draguer une cause est par exemple
on est ici si tu sors avec moi je te
baisse des impôts plus avant sur celle
inverse
est-ce que vous avez été déjà victime de
harcèlement sexuel de l'or ben c'est ce
soir
c'est bon on sait que vous êtes marié à
chantal delsol depuis maintenant 29 ans
pour que trente ans ça si vous n'étiez
pas marié bouton vous était tombé
amoureux d'une d'une femme politiquement
opposées à vos idées est-ce que c'est
ses propres idées et cette opposition
aura été une entrave à votre relation
est ce que vous pensez qu'il faut je
mens je pense que pour pouvoir se marier
avec quelqu'un il faut avoir un même
projet de vie vous auriez jamais pu
épouser une fille du pc par exemple je
pense que j'aurais eu quelques petits
problèmes puisque d'amour nomade afibel
vous plaît vous l'adorez les belles vous
faites l'amour merveilleusement avec
elle et elle est du pc qu'est ce qui se
passe je l'a convertie à fait d'accord
vous avez donc double eagle et les
dépôts que s'est porté le mieux sur
votre femme
s'étonna cité nous sommes en tête n'en
parlez pas de la durée de votre mariage
en disant ça obligatoirement pas
bretonne ne verrez pas bretonne est bon
j'imagine que comme tout homme amoureux
de sa femme vous devez être un petit peu
jaloux est ce que ça vous est déjà
arrivé de fouiller dans le sac de votre
femme pour garder son carnet d adresses
pour pouvoir téléphoner mais après lui
avoir demandé l'autorisation et par
action et si l écouter les messages de
vos téléphones portables ça me fâche ray
je trouve pas ça très élégant ça vous
ferait non faut se reprendre ce que je
suis maintenant arena qu'elles sont
autant d'expériences nigérian décochait
d'abord puis je me dis je trouve pas ça
très élégante c'est tout c'est plutôt un
porte jarretelles culotte petit bateau
je suis de de ce que ma femme mais ce
qu'elles paient à se mettre d quoi
vous permet de garder mes habiletés et
elle était habillée comment l'ana fois
où il avait vu juste une robe blanche à
vous en souvenez vous de cinq ans de
mariage les mecs se souviennent plus du
tout la place ensemble est un pays est
censé dernière une petite robe blanche
une robe blanche petit petit mais
chantal fut comme dira chantal que
félicitations parce qu'après 30 ans de
mariage et souvient encore de la façon
dont vous êtes les billets bravo ça
c'est un bon
si vous étiez une femme à qu'aimeriez
vous ressemblez vous avez vous avez
votre temps pascal sevran
pascal sevran suggère jamel debbouze
mais je vais vous donner un petit truc
comme ça vous et aux questions
difficiles au madame belpaire deloche si
vous avez le temps de réfléchir mais on
sait si vous êtes une femme vous verriez
vous ressemblez je sais pas mais je
continuais les a pas de réflexion
il faut vivre ses fantasmes jusqu'au
bout donc ça doit rester du domaine du
rêve qui dépend de nature des fantasmes
je parle fantasme en général c'est pas
uniquement il fonda semaine sexuelle
savoir tassement général
non on ne parle pas que de ça ici de
suivre un employé alors moi c'est pas du
tout les missions dans la question
c'est une histoire extraordinaire et
romantique je suis pour eux la poussée
jusqu'au bout ils n'ont encore une
question aussi
non on va s'arrêter là je pense que ça
vous restez avec nous jusqu'à la fin de
l'émission
mais avant d'accueillir notre invité
suivant je voudrais parler de votre
avenir en politique parce que finalement
nous on sait pas vous pensez que
l'avenir politique sinon vous ne vous ne
seriez pas là
nous on n'en sais rien je suis là et on
est ravi que vous soyez là bon on parle
beaucoup du fait que vous rejoignez le
parti de charles pasqua et philippe de
villiers qui s'appelle le rpf mais bon
il ya un peu des problèmes parce que
villiers puis j'ai dû rester numéro deux
il apporte filet se faire piquer sans
job de numéro deux c'est normal et puis
lui si les souverainistes et vous vous
êtes européen quand même non bon alors
est ce que vous serez un jour maire ps
de lyon
on n'en sait rien quel est l'avenir de
votre parti la droite qui quand même
avec 2 % d'intentions de vote aux
européennes ce qui va obliger à renoncer
et on a appris cette semaine le départ
du numéro 2 de votre parti fresque qui
dit maintenant le front national et
l'arrière était laminé la droite n'a
plus de raison d'exister donc pour
connaître votre avenir politique
linda va vous tirer les cartes
alors vous avez déjà consulté une
voyante jamais pensé que les hommes
politiques jamais mais saluant les tons
sont prévoyants rendre à un bal
vous êtes les lignes de la main vous en
choisissez cette vous voulez donner face
cachée aulas il faut penser à quelque
chose il faut être un peu plus là je
vous sens qu'il croit pas ses cartes
parce que chérie tu vas nous est
septième avec un nom m'a tiré le
portrait linda ça a priori comme ça ça
vous ça vous dit quoi ça c'est pas c'est
pas mauvais et le pic c'est vrai qu'ils
aient pas donc là on voit cadets pour
prochaine pour chiens de millions des
circonstances favorables
un projet professionnel vous êtes
il ya un homme qui est généreux
tellement serviable borgne il n'est pas
borgne --- c'est charles pasqua
c'est peut-être charles pasqua créé là
pour vous aider donc ça se passe assez
bien
et oui oui ça se passe assez bien et en
fait il ya quelque chose qui peut
arriver d'assez important pour votre
avenir politique
c'est déjà discuté avec le rpf non parce
que c'est très positif mais il faut
demander à linda y voit alors par contre
on sent qu au départ ça commence assez
bien donc vous avez le soutien à
quelqu'un
mannum d'un homme d'un certain âge un
peu plus de 50 ans et ensuite y en eu
alors je sais pas si c'est une rupture
un découragement et qu'il se passe
quelque chose de da cdh assez compliqué
alors peut-être que vous êtes à
découvert
non il ya belle pique la réplique
donc en fait alors c'est la détériore
c'est aussi la détérioration de certains
liens alors peut-être sa détérioration
avec des liens passés c'est peut-être
cette personne par son aide et votre
association avec cette personne qui va
faire que vous allez que certains liens
du passé simple nda c'est pasqua mais
j'ai charles millon a laissé tomber son
parti pour internet ici voilà pour
rejoindre et puis finalement ils disent
de coeur le set de coeur toi s'est très
bien passé c'est très très bien ces
rencontres amoureuses ça c'est un grand
succès et de lyon au coeur le set de
coeur saigne le normand est généralement
liée à la famille et notamment aux
enfants
mettez une carte sur le site de coeur à
le pic
non mais ça c'est une sas et l'herbe
c'est à dire qui ont surgi dans votre
votre vie et de dire vous avez fumé de
l'herbe en abondance non là j'arrive pas
à l'aise je sais pas mais je sais pas
même pas une fois pour goûter vous
pouvez remédier excusez moi j'aime bien
mais bon ça me permettre une autre carte
celle ci parce qu'en fait le roi de
pique donc là c'est lié à l'amour
le roi de pique annonce une un avocat tu
vas l'emprise ombre c'est un avocat
huissier ou je ne sais pas la cia
l'amour donc bon mais par contre ça se
termine assez bien las de trélazé linda
l'as de trèfle
c'est c'est un success une récompense
bon ça va alors enfin globalement ça va
ça va assez bien
ballack revient très bien pourquoi voilà
merci dit mme david jamais on
il s'agit pas de savoir si vous allez
remplir le bataclan patiemment pierre
labat elle m'a dit lu plein au bataclan
doit encore loin de là faut pas dire ça
ah bon on a du temps quand même un truc
du monde
ouais combien 80000 personnes c'est
beaucoup c'est ce que fait céline dion
en un soir ça oui ça m'énerve
vous restez avec nous 1 donc le focus va
être un peu moins sur vous mais vous
vous restez là dire absolument tout ce
que vous voulez on va recevoir
maintenant quelqu'un qui s'appelle jean
rachid alors jean rachid sais pas si
vous vous le connaissez jean rachid non
mais tu rachid c'est un mec marrant
c'est à dire c'est un type qui a fait un
disque qui s'appelle parodie zia qu'avec
lui reprend comme ça il fait des
parodies de chansons de rappeurs et lui
il trouve en fait que les que les
rappeurs français c'est-à-dire les
présents de stomy bugzy dorothée du rap
français lui pense que stomy bugzy doc
gynéco c'est une expression très à la
mode al dorothée des beurs j'étais pas
là dorothée détient 10 ans non je ne
crois pas donc doc gynéco passi stomy
bugzy aura tout seul ministère amer il
trouve qu'ils sont un peu ringard parce
qu'il chante finalement des trucs qui
sont un peu guimauve un peu walt disney
quoi et est lui en revanche il veut que
ses chansons disent quelque chose il
veut lutter contre les clichés qui sont
dans dans le rap français alors c'est un
disque et présentées par dieudonné je
vous conseille d'acheter le disque est
très très bien présentées par dieudonné
en la chanson qu'on va écouter ce soir
c'est mon papa à moi
voici jean rachid
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
haedo et marie le pen sorties tout droit
tu ne vas pas une folle tous les aider
il m'emmène à vitrolles
fatigué des élections agité dit que
c'est pour se reposer mais il fait des
clins d'oeil
ascenseur bien mais il est obligé parce
qu'il en ait un il m'a offert un jeu de
fléchettes
est avec une carte de l'algérie pour que
je m'entraîne à tirer comme lui
pour le cas où il irait à
mantes-la-jolie agressé le maire avec
ses amis et dire au tribunal qui ne l'a
pas touché même s'ils avaient des
caméras étaient braquées sur toi mon
petit papa et moi je te crois les
mitaines des balles pour tirer sur les
biches et des conseils pour coller les
affiches je ne touchais leur cible mais
seulement quand le salam la chercher
quand tu me parles de la guerre il me
dit que c'est rigolo hitler et klaus
barbie sans ces super héros
mon papa est gentil il aime pas les
méchants sa couleur préférée c'est le
blanc quand ils entendent par pau on
n'est pas mort parce qu'il a beaucoup
trop d'argent pour qu'on dise qu'il
adore
eto'o
m
[Musique]
amado et p
il a voté vous en avez
appelle papa
et dans
[Musique]
à moi et deux
mais
il épousa marie le pen plus vite
histoire touche pas à ça si les gens
n'avaient nulle sauraient pas voté pour
moi de l'union des sélecteurs ça
rapporte à l'appel alors fais pas le con
si tu veux toujours ton fusil à noël
le savoir est une arme maintenant tu
sais qu'il est important que ceux qui
votent pour moi soit désarmé quand
j'arrive au cours de tromper les gens me
prennent la tête à la chasse au sanglier
les gens viennent me parler bébé ton
père m3 gamme y at il déjà tué
mty bruno mégret après je vois ta tête
sur les jours dort comme un facho qu'on
peut pas traîner devant les tribunaux
tu installe un énorme toujours t'écraser
on peut même plus poussé quelqu'un dans
la selle pour rigoler c'est les immigrés
tout ça pour le moment je t'expliquerai
ma version la seconde guerre mondiale
une fois plus grande et s'ils continuent
à t'énerver dit
bien que tous les week-ends en autriche
pardo qui vient nous
[Musique]
ouais ouais merci à signer assez haut
avec nos gens
bon alors excédé par le 10 à 15 ans mais
c'est bien là on a annoncé l'onu la
vérité c'est qu'on a reçues le cd on a
trouvé c'est génial on dit on l'invité à
séoul hier vous savez je demande
d'applaudir jean rachid
merci merci beaucoup d'autres lauriers à
l'oreillette on me dit par exemple on
m'a dit voilà là tu vois là ça devient
un peu lourd là ça fait un peu vrai mais
ménagez pas les mêmes influences voit
alors se voir qu'est-ce qu'elle excuse
moi si je pensais pas voir si c'est ce
que vous pouvez dire un truc à te faire
[ __ ] ouais bah si c'est toi tu as
faim qui parle au micro je suis un robot
mais en fait on tente à lantages et
aucun terrain moi je fais que ce qu'on
me dit dans lequel on est aussi d'avis
qu'il faut qu'on dit donc maintenant on
me dit ça c'est toi jamel
donc maintenant on me dit dans
l'oreillette justement on m'a dit que
l'on va accueillir quelqu'un quelqu'un
quand même beau alors je vous expliquais
un truc dans cette émission cette année
avec catherine barma
on a pris une grande décision c'est en
variété d'inviter les gens qui nous
plaisent voilà c'est clair simple net et
précis et on adore et voilà celle qui
vient d'avoir le principe s'est invitée
ce qui nous plaisent à une vedette ou
deux pas plus pas par émission et ce
soir ben jacobs quelqu'un qui nous plaît
beaucoup
son surnom c'est la seule aux yeux bleus
c'est joli la sole j'essaie qui s'est
battue et qui s'est s'est axé leur aide
mais là
bonsoir voila champignons ils n'arrivent
jamais l'accès leur aide
donc voilà alors axel donc il vaut
dernier cd qui s'appelle toujours moi il
ya beaucoup de bonnes chansons il y en a
deux qui sent personnellement je suis
égoïste 1 c'est mon show voilà y en a
deux que j'aime beaucoup c'est ce matin
et et faire des mamours voilà ce qu'on
sait pas vous concernant c'est qu'en
fait vous êtes auteur compositeur
chanteur et comme vous êtes une fille
déjà on devrait dire auteur compositeur
deux chanteuses
non non moi votre c'est décevant bien je
ne me plains pas ces règles étaient
cette nuit calme et très franc je sens
mieux qu ophélie winter par exemple je
ne connais pas ces chiffres mais je le
mien se porte bien alors non le problème
justement c'est le bébé parce que c'est
un problème c'est pas le problème c'est
surtout son nom voilà janelle voilà mais
comment peut-on appeler un enfant
janelle mais comme ça ton enfant mais
oui et tout le monde l'appelle jamais la
cause de toi mais grâce à moi grâce à
toi et j'ai lu quand j'étais au maroc
qui on m'a dit que jamais elle j'aime
mieux ça veut dire beau ouais ça
maintenant je l'appelais jamel et j'ai
mangé moi je l'appelais janelle et le
sondage annuel mais parce que c'est
jamais jamais je change elle
les jays belles chansons say média
d'après jeune j'avais oublié que c'était
quand même
elle était maudite oui même à l'école
c'est beau la presse comment va galérer
je vais vous dire la vérité j'ai lu dans
le pire des ddd magazine un magazine à
scandale américain voilà c'était une
histoire je vais pas vous raconter
laquelle parce que sinon janelle elle
pour appeler à mettre portant des gants
mais c'était vraiment un article à
scandale et je voyais le nom et jeux wii
est pris et j'aime beaucoup jamais alors
je me dis pourquoi mon label rationnelle
si vous voulez bien est ce que votre
mari ça que ça se passe comment un
ministre local et ses millions ma fille
je l'appellerai john l c'est moi jte
autres barry white avec vous dans la rue
ça se passe bien c'est le ccaf vous
l'avait épousée dix ans après votre
premier baiser ce que cammas et on a
hésité longtemps
il en a pas marre votre mari parce que
je regardais quand même moi je sais pas
le soin avant de vous coucher vous
prenez b1 b2 b3 b6 du magnésium du
potassium du calcium boules quiès dans
les oreilles masque sur les yeux et ça
fait dix ans qu'ils sont parfois des
chaussettes mais seuls les chauffeurs
éviter mais comme mon français de dormir
en plus c'est pas que sa situation d'ici
il a le choix aux monuments aux métiers
ou miage ou mais les chaussettes et ils
préfèrent ne pas massés au pied ça
dépend c'est comme quand je propose est
ce que c'est ça que je cuisine où on va
au mcdonald's malgré les chaussettes
malgré les boules quiès le masque sur
les yeux le magnésium le calcium le
potassium ça fait quand même dix ans
qu'on est ensemble ouais mais en même
temps ça te regarde comment les jeunes
les jeunes hommes mais il a il est
arrivé je crois qu'il a beaucoup de
patience
c'est le magazine julian finn aussi vous
avez une chose en commun c'est que vous
avez tous les deux étaient des grands
fans de louis de funès tout à l'heure
comparé à coluche propos aussi durs
louis de funès et vous aussi vous avez
comment j'ai appris le français en
regardant louis de funès mais oui
j'adore ma vie tu m'as pas non plus qu
un truc exceptionnel qui aujourd'hui
apparemment les plus possible d'après ce
que j'ai entendu je m'éclate et lui son
personnage pendant pratiquement 20 piges
et extraordinaire qui vous fait un grand
pas pour but bourvil et louis de funès
mon temps quand ils jouent des films
comme la folie des grandeurs l'aspect il
vous fait rire que des marins comme un
visiteur veut dire un truc sur les
tunnels ccc comme le disco c'est comme
ouais je veux dire un moment donné ça ce
n'est pas bien de dire allez dire des
souris mâles non non je viens où la
demande est à la mode
c'est exactement c'est exactement que me
guy bedos
je voulais juste dire qu'ils sont que
contre hautmont les légendes qui nous
oppose systématiquement dans la presse
interposée puisqu'on ne voit jamais je
les aime beaucoup mais voilà je mets mes
deux semaines alors on va passer
maintenant on va passer
axel traitance or vous avez sa lettre du
report ou peut se compter pas sur
millions pour vous aider dans ce qui
arrive maintenant au lieu de parler
choisir des chansons de soldes stacks
d'otis redding steve coiffeur enfin
toutes vos idoles comme ça isaac hayes
ça vous connaissez par coeur à votre
maman avait tous ses disques donc ce
serait ça serait trop facile
en retenant plus vous passer du david
baccarat d'aion warwick et tout ça parce
que tout ça vous connaissez par coeur on
appris des chanteurs ou des chanteurs
qui sont roux des chanteuses ans en
route au moment va sur la politique
yacine mourad ben vous avez sur la
pochette atteint parce qu'après on va
changer le jour où vous êtes vous êtes
blonde ouvert qui n'est pas très joli
titien que la majorité des européens sa
vache d'arc a quitté rennes avait les
cheveux que de vaches ouverte à qui et
ce avec hilda est une vraie brunel
oui bruxelles ça va très très bien merci
pis en votre nom c'est à cause des
chevaux à cause de titres et des scellés
l'ascenseur aux us
ouais j'ai pensé après monfils a dit
avoir été bien utile si on était mieux
que jen est là alors donc on va
commencer vous êtes prête vous vous
concentrez n'est jamais elle ne va pas
être pourront ils nous regardent et john
lange suis désolé mais on t'appellera
djamel puis c'est tout moi j'ai un ami
qui vient d'appeler sa fille chloé on
est quand alors est ce qu'on est prêt à
l'escwa la lumière y entend la voix la
high tech
le test alors didier tu es prêt première
chanson pleine de jeunesse
[Musique]
bah c'est un hymne à compter les points
oui bien sûr il ya des prix aussi il ya
un prix à s'étirer qu'ils soient les
rouges
non mais là où phone house et les rouges
en a dit les roues voilà on a dit les
roues donc je pensais le cd de la hausse
au pour que tout le monde puisse voir
effectivement qu'elle est vraiment route
ça bougeait bien alors il faut rien dire
de mal sur la rousseau je dis ça pour
vous qui la connaissaient pas
spécialement ce qu'elle met des coups de
poing
[Musique]
premier en mesures beaucoup plus dures
parce que c'est un personnage angélique
chante non très étrange
ma paie pas avoir un tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette affaire
[Musique]
j'ai compris
saillant
[Musique]
c'est pas dans la direction d'arrêter le
jeu
madonna n'ont plus la dérange aussi
verser introuvable enfin sachez ni
comment tu sais ça il a vu sa fiche
il est venu à bout d'un moment j'ai pu
voir ta fiche aller d'un terrain il a
pas vu ma fille j'ai bon mais comment il
cessa lui
[Applaudissements]
et
c'est une fille qui n'existe pas un
personnage en 3d un peu comme lara croft
comment elle existe elle est très connue
c'est très connu sous les noms c'est un
personnage en production ces synthèses
sur mtv très souvent voilà oui et il est
trop bon
j'ai de l'argent maintenant j'ai le
câble ces règlements mon disque ne
savons pas encore assez mince et très
très bien là bravo
wayne rooney fort il est fort joli nom
avec lui à le test non liquides in his à
quoi alors maintenant on continue on
compte didier alma mylène pourvu
qu'elles soient douces
est-ce que jamel est ce que vous avez
déjà lu les paroles qui sont au verso de
ce disque là pourvu qu'elles soient
douces nom des minutes mais non je
serais moi j'espère c'est vous
connaissez pas vous avez jamais eu la
présence d'esprit de retourner le jeu
c'est dsk
moi j'ai pas les céder pourquoi pas mais
c'est une chanson en fait sur la sodomie
non c'est vrai on sentait bien la
tequila gère ses chansons sur l'assaut
de je trouve que c'est vrai tu as
cherché un moteur est chanson numéro 5
didier
wade au cajon
le poil de carotte amadeus est une
punition détermination à brett n'est pas
de punition c'est zéro à des montois
j'ai essayé d'ouvrir canadienne j'ai
fait ce que j'avais vu ses expéditions
sans toi
c'est une canadienne elle arrive dès
lors ce jour je l ai beaucoup chez
drucker et j'espère que le loto qui a
écrit pour la belle et la bête notre
dame de paris
voilà il a écrit que ce soit isabelle
boulay bravo m
mais non seulement à la donne et les
transmet la biographie de ces deux
acceptent vous êtes en train de faire un
score fantastique et concentrez-vous
malin il a d'un petit peu didier surtout
sur ni caméra ni longer la recherche et
[Applaudissements]
voilà le disque de mylène farmer pour
choeur horrifié l'irlande puissiez lire
les paroles au verso on s'intéresse
alors je vais faire semblant que jamel
lit les paroles de pourvu qu'elles
soient douces avait montré à la caméra
sic et voilà voilà ni jamais rien
revendiqué mais ni qui voit là isabelle
boulay mesdames messieurs
hélas non pas et sherwood cher on nous
le montrer parce que ça vient d'être
trouvée je pense que c'est une nouveau
après bill est vrai bon on continue
alors qu'eux mêmes
djamel à s'y attendait c'est pour ça
allait toulouse les frères s'est fait
tout c'est pour ça que jamais réaliser
la pochette c'est parce que je veux pas
être accusé de tricher mais ça j'aurais
pu tout aimé ces pauvres eux m'a dit
mettez ça dans sa chanson non oui j'ai à
lui dire
mylan je savais pas moins qualité comme
ça me gêne je pense qu'elle va en
revendre la médaille si tu m'écoutes
sache que j'aime bien tes paroles c'est
vrai jésus bonjour juste car au hockey
mais c'est pas vrai c'est pas obscène
c'est chez tous et tous ces mots côte à
côte pour des phrases essaie de les dire
non on continue donc on continue avec la
dernière chanson
dans quels héraults ceci un gaz
c'est pas c'est pas mon domaine c'est
dur était passé par août
je cache
là je peux te dire
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'original c'est dans la suite
bon ben moi franchement franchement vous
savez si coin et ça fait deux points
dans notre ami djamel pas mal d'excusés
on pas mal géant 2.3 non mais bon est-ce
que 2 pauline ester niger trois points
mais j'ai pu et je suis les achète un
bien bon axel vous restez avec nous
djamel vous restez avec nous charles
vous restez avec nous on va passer à la
séquence suivante on peut remonter les
lumières merci et j'accueille les stylos
et si la rencontre soir je pense à linda
hardy
connaissez vous allez connaître ont
trouvé quatre jamais elle vous
connaissez sûrement ça axelle red
jean billon jeu sinon alors christine
arron médaille d'argent au relais 4 x
100 m a sévi c'est pour ça un petit peu
quand vous invitez on peut le dire oui
je vais quand même si ça fait plaisir
bah ouais j'espère que ça fait plaisir
en toile c'était très contente des
médailles bien sûr j'ai bien sûr
reprendre un appel beaux arts mais non
c'est bien j'étais restée très content
c'est à dire quand même temps une course
enfin ça dure très dure mais c'est fois
c'est très long dans votre tête c'est
non ça va très vite c'est vrai c'est un
très vite surtout un 100 m bon c -
demont secondes ça que ça s'est passé
très vite émergé pour un truc qui dure
dix secondes mais ce qui est assez quoi
en fait on travaille toute l'année pour
une course qui va durer - non c'est
assez fou dont il faut pas rater
l'événement il faut être prêt pour cette
loi va gagner un port sagan ya bien sûr
une mission j'en sens à autre chose mais
justement pas défaitiste quoi sinon ça
va pas on va vous regarder courir
et puis après on continuera à discuter
magnéto serge
[Musique]
or
question
mais question culture lupine est ce que
bon le passage du relais
est-ce que c'est sexuel je sais pas ce
que je vois toutes ces filles qui se
passe ce machin comme ça je me dis non
je vois ça comme ça quoique ces
questions c'est pas tout
une sur deux j'avais pas pensé à ça sent
vraiment bien joué ce truc là mais un
donneur et un receveur c'est comme ça
parce qu'il ya transmission des cieux je
crois qu'elle va quand même beaucoup
plus vite maintenant
ouais ils n'ont jamais pensé non j'ai
commencé dit tout à ça mais c'est vrai
que c'est moi c'est de cette course là
vous étiez dopé ou non non jamais alors
je n'étais pas dopé non non ne vois pas
ce que ça te va pas si de ma façon de
voir le sport je vois plus un sport
propre et avec plein de valeurs je pense
pas que ce soit utile à tout ça c'était
pas en france je n'ai pas de contrôle
sanguin pas de compte c'est vrai c'est
je l'avais plus vous dopez
tranquillement je vais même on sais pas
qu'est-ce qui est protégé ou pas tous
comme ça mais c'est vrai que c'est
j'aurais bien aimé qu'à la fin de chaque
course et dans les championnats comme ça
y est les courbes contrôles sanguins
parce que franchement je pense qu'il ya
un bon nettoyage à faire j'ai entendu
encore aujourd'hui un médecin qui me
disait que en fait ceux qui gagnent qui
sont les meilleurs sont des gens qui se
dopent pas mais qui sont pas
hypoglycémiques sait gérer compris ce
qu'il a dit je sais qu'il ya beaucoup
d'américains qui souhaite s'attacher
forcément déjà été dopés déjà du mal à
moi je veux pas tomber dans ce système
allait dire que les personnes qui
gagnent qui sont devant moi sont dopés
ça pas du tout je pense qu'on est
capable de faire de très belles
performances ensemble avoue alors
apparemment oui voilà way
quand ya pas de contrôles sanguins quand
chaque des contrôles d'uriné envoie pas
le bo exactement dix ans la norme de
référence
voilà leur joie non mais je peux gagner
j'ai gagné l'an dernier à budapest qui
était chanteuse europe et j'espère bien
être championne olympique du 800 m dans
des endroits alors qu'un jour
vous dites sans drogue comme on
applaudit comme si c'était
extraordinaire superbe
oui c'est magnifique c'est bien même
parfois à budapest dont vous a été
championne d'europe du 4 x 100 m vous
êtes drapés dans le drapeau français
parce que avez-vous dit avait pas de
drapeau guadeloupéens
oui je suis française mais avant tout
guadeloupéen non mais de toute façon je
n'aurais pas pris de drogue d'armes ou
perçu relie drapé dans un drapeau
guadeloupéens non non non non toute
façon s'ils tentent la guadeloupe n'est
pas indépendante je n'aurai pas à me
drapé dans un wagg dans un drapeau ou à
louper un exemple et indépendantistes
que je voulais que chaque moment je suis
pas indépendantiste pas du tout parce
que bon je sais très bien que la
guadeloupe a besoin du soutien de la
france
oui c'est vrai qu'on voit tout et
catastrophes qu'il peut y avoir un
guadeloupéen tout ce qu'on a besoin de
construire
donc je pense qu'on a besoin de la
france et je suis une guadeloupéenne
française voilà pourquoi est ce que vous
dites que quand vous gagnez vous êtes
française et quand vous perdez vous êtes
antillaise c'est ce qu'on dit c'est ce
qu'on dit en général c'est ce que disent
les journalistes et voilà quand on a
gagné ce sera la française a gagné 1
médaille date dans et si je perds ce
serait quand l'histoire de la boissière
10 à la fin qu'au français même quand il
est génial on dit qu'il est français
bien sûr bien évidemment bien évidemment
on lui a dit lui légèrement côté
français on dit surtout quand il remplit
des salles et tout ça c'est normal vous
êtes très star mais je veux censure on
voit d'une couleur différente vais
installer coquet avec ok après très
grave c'est une femme et pour une
sportive
je ne sais pas amélie mauresmo ont quoi
match et bien voilà c'est tout
non mais je sentais mieux la tisza gère
déjà les aléas des bonnes amélie
mauresmo
oui au tennis c'est ce que je voulais
dire oui j avoue que tu as compris quoi
rien d'autre à voilà donc vous avez
maintenant vous êtes coquette c'est
vraiment les cheveux vous avez 30 paires
de chaussures ah non je n'ai plus
peut-être mis en vente qui mêle d'un
marcos et 3000 elle la femme du
dictateur de défier des pinottes vous
êtes à combien de paires de chaussures
ça c'est pas du tout elle ne sait pas si
les patientes et moins que celui du
helmand oui merci à moins qu'ils
m'aident à marcos et ses lignes ont le
nez vous un petit ou un petit piercing
je vois pas bien en qu'il est mignon il
est ou pas simuler la tatouages oui j'en
ai deux que cinq mois à la cheville de
tous ceux qui n'avalent situation que
n'a pas de signification ya passé par
des gens nés en ce qu'elle épaule qui
signifie c'est leur idole on peut le
voir s'échanger de la route et
franchement si on compte bien l'antenne
que vous laisser les chiens et chats il
est juste là qu'est ce que ça veut dire
c'est la symbol alors en fait de l'or
elle est très branché 10 juin vous êtes
aussi quand même sponsor et par la
mairie de paris s'avouant sponsorisé par
an excusez moi monsieur des boules ça
vous embête pas de vous montrer avec
jean tiberi non pas vraiment parce que
moi en fait je suis plus à la mairie de
paris parce qu'en fait je envie de
promouvoir mon sport et par
l'intermédiaire de la mairie de paris
j'ai cette occasion la de promouvoir mon
sport au jardin des montagnes hommes
entrent bien je suis pas je suis pas là
pour être avec jean tiberi c'est plus
une image sportive que jamais véhiculer
et je suis surtout pas dans aucun parti
politique que ce soit ça se passe très
bien
alors donc vous avez un garçon enfin
garçons jules quoi qui s'appelle dan
philibert oui un qui est champion de 110
m e et honnêtement vous arrivez à rester
fidèles avec tous ces beaux athlètes
quand vous voyez dans l'est dans les
vestiaires non mais je sais pas vous
faites
ouais bien sûr non avait pas j'ai pas
spécialement de tentation c'est vrai
quoi - des sportifs qui sont beaux mais
j'ai l'habitude justement de voir de
beaux athlètes donc maintenant ça
devient plus plus courant quand on est
donc
vous dites que vous seriez prêt à tout
abandonner pour un homme dans les
limites du raisonnable
l'audience qui en fait tout abandonner
c'est pas vraiment raisonnable voilà
donc c'est quoi la limite du raisonnable
je sais pas c'est
cochard nous a dit tout à l'heure c'est
sentir quelque chose pour lui mais ça me
dérange franchement pas vraiment à quoi
faut qu'ils aient un compromis et que ça
chauffe aussi quelqu'un de demandes tout
abandonner je le ferai pas
mais si tu seras mon choix personnel je
pourrai alors maintenant ce que je vous
propose c'est de voir dan philibert donc
qui est le vôtre compagnon on peut dire
c'est marion vient c est votre fiancée
c'est d'ailleurs justement on dit on dit
que pour les garçons l'acte sexuel et
recommence recommandé avant l'exploit
sportif est ce que pour les filles c'est
pareil non moi je suis jamais jamais
spécialement entendu ça je pense que la
meilleure chose tu as déjà se sentir
bien bon si on a envie de se libérer
avant une compétition et que ça ça nous
dit stresse comme ça nous libyens
bouffeurs quoi dire faut pas nous en
poser des questions c'est tout le monde
tirait alors mais moi non mais attendez
c'est pas moi j'ai des enfants alors
serge chevalier tout on regarde ben
philibert c'est l'histoire de deux
paysans qui ont deux champs la main côté
de l'eau et ses chambres donnent sur une
sur une falaise et danses et chants et
des chevaux donc il y en a tous les
jours il ya tricherie qui tombe comme ça
et
tous les jours y perd un cheval donc il
a dégoûté parce que son voisin à côté il
ya tous ces chevaux ils sont là bien au
complet donc il va voir son voisin il
lui dit des voisins comment vous faites
moi tous les jours je perds un cheval où
ils sont tous là au complet
vous avez un secret oui j'ai un secret
oui j'ai un âne dans mon champ lan pedro
pouvez m'expliquer un peu parce que là
je comprends pas comment ça fonctionne
pedro lan arrête la chute des chevaux
c'est pedro pedro lan arrête de chute de
cheveux
vraiment c'était trop mais non c'est
pedro op non c'est pas super douala
n'arrête gîte des chevaux à visiter il
est drôle à s'entendre et bien tous les
deux à vous et des ménages et non pas
encore parce que voilà maintenant que
vous m'ayez 100 mille francs par mois à
fontenay-sous-bois remarquer lui il
habite toujours à trappes en même temps
vous a dit que le sait n'ont personne à
bord maintenant non mais non c'est parce
je gagne pas ça par mois déjà
donc fontenay-sous-bois c'est très bien
c'est vraiment sévère s'est calmée
manque de place maintenant qu'on sait
que j'ai envie de déménager
moi aussi je vais déménager avant pour
aller du côté imposable de la ville de
trappes jamais le côté obscur
pourquoi attrape pourquoi pas paris
parce que c'est bien c'est comme si
j'habitais au bureau je peux que m'en
expliquer l'étude deux ans et puis tu
vas travailler direct c'est bien d'avoir
un petit coin en retrait mais à des
petits coins sympas mais là où je suis
je te jure c'est vraiment bien en dehors
de ça c'est la classe
alors dites-moi dernière chose la vie
parisienne est ce que vous êtes comme
djamel pour qui c'est un petit peu le un
peu les hébreux qui adore le veau d'or
quoi un peu un peu le côté obscur comme
il dit la vie parisienne ce sont mes
filles est ce que vous en méfiez vous
fois disons que c'est une ville spéciale
surtout pour moi qui je viens d il donc
c'est vrai qu'au début quand tu arrives
à paris c'était vraiment très difficile
tout est expliqué mauvais temps surtout
en voyant plus où il faisait froid donc
cesser complètement différent de la
guadeloupe donc c'est vrai que moi au
début j'ai vraiment eu du mal à
m'adapter je me surprenais des fois
marcher vite comme les gens alors
comment je suis super nombre d'écoles en
cours et s'est vite plus vite que les
joies mais ouais mais dans la vie je
suis vraiment beaucoup plus cool
tranquille pour faire tout ce que j'ai à
faire quoi
et c'est vrai que là c'est bien pour ça
va me dit vous êtes puissante mais pas
très nerveuse non c'est vrai enfin
nerveuse sérieuse sur la gère mais des
fois je m'énerve vite
dites moi christine arron vous avez dire
non parce que je parlais de la vie
parisienne là il faut quand même vous
faire accepter oblige à bouger les frais
fort vous disent que vous dites je
regrette me regarde je sais pas non mais
je ne sais pas parce qu'en plus vous
parlez très bien enfin nom vous dit
emmanuelle béart à une prétention qui ne
déplaît parce que oui c'était dans sa
façon de parler sa façon d'être qui me
plaît c'est pas celle qui vous déplacer
sa prétention non non non non c'est
juste sa prétention très bien dernière
question les invités qui sont autour de
cette table où les voiliers dans quelle
catégorie d'athlétisme 100 millions par
exemple vous voyez faire quoi
[Musique]
j'ai pas pts et le lancer de poids
peut-être lancer du javelot à tâtons
lancé web lancer du javelot lancer de
javelot way djamel attention à ce que tu
feras ponts distants supplia du jamais
vu son lancer de vannes quoi je tiens
mais peut-être 100 m 200 m sans langue
son langage moi j'ai fait c'est beaucoup
il ya toujours un grand concours à des
teams en belgique chaque année et on m'a
j'ai chanté pour l'ouverture et j'ai dû
lancer le compte à personne
voilà je sens la version
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est atterré juste devant les pieds et
thierry ardisson j'aime bien qu'habitant
situé sur la tête à 800 le 800 well as
dix ans on alors de pro la huawei semer
la licence et en coin du sprint il faut
toujours le dernier
oui et pourquoi pas sur lui parce que
justement pas le soir c'est peut-être de
croire de 800 bien merci sydney alors
vous nous ramener une médaille d'or
j'espère voulait pas clean d'aboutir les
cartes pour n'est vraiment sûr non ça
pour quoi non mais bon à mon avis il
faut mais je m'entraîne bien pour aller
vite et charlie dont on me dit dans
l'oreillette ça serait bien là qu'on ait
une réaction de charles millon est ce
que vous avez une réaction parce que
c'est revoir je suis pas sûr tout ce
qu'on vient de dire n'importe quoi vous
dites que vous voulez c'est juste une
réaction de sa part de dire à christine
arron que si une société veut s'ouvrir
eh bien il faut qu'elle trouve en fait
des personnes un peu emblématique et on
peut remercier christine et la route de
cette personne mais voilà catherine
barma
de servir qu'à tout démarre mal merci
alors maintenant on va passer au flop du
moment le jingle
les flops du moment qu'est ce qui est le
flop en ce moment pour vous charles
millon qu'est-ce qui présente le rpr
depuis depuis la mort de de gaulle ya
plus que le bordel qu'il soit général
rpr et robert russell celle seul qui
fait du pognon avec leur père qu est ce
qu a d'autres pour vous comme flop je
donne un exemple de flop le flop
le fn fait un flop parce que tout ce que
je parle du de même que je connais bien
c'est la droite parlementaire qui fait
flop
oui fait flop c'est la raison pour
laquelle démocratie claudique que vous
avez la partie gauche qui portent bien
et puis la partie droite qui est
paralysé mais fléchit flop en ce moment
pour vous par ophélie winter a déjà
parlé ça serait pas sympa non pas du
tout non non non je vous demande ce que
vous semblez mal connue l'équipe de
france je resterai dans mon domaine moi
je crois que free flop ce qu'est ce que
tu es en train de se passer c'est les
disques qu'on peut les compagnies ce
qu'on peut copier je veux dire sans
lever les lélés les trois les trois aux
auteurs et aux compositeurs voilà voilà
je lui le schpountz dans les films du
riz pour sa magie oui j'aime bien ce
responsable j'aime bien smaïn j'aime
bien
azéma j'aime bien intitulé le cadeau
j'aime bien au riz j'ai vu de ce putsch
et qui fait mais ça va passer c'est
dommage que le public n'ait pas suivi
ah oui oui même temps je l'aide
[Applaudissements]
alors anelka avec est ce qu'il faut
aller le cas maintenant deux minutes
chéri il arrive l'attenté du cas il
prend 200 millions et tous les jours tu
vois la même réaction que tous les
bouffons de journalistes là qui le lui
le pauvre ils arrivent ils à 20 piges il
n'est pas responsable de cette pression
il arrive dans une équipe du real de
madrid où tout est déjà très bien
établie il faut qu'il fasse ses marques
il était fait ces déclarations sont les
autres joueurs comme quoi les autres
joueurs a été médiocre non non jamais
les coûts par alliance non c'est pas
vrai non vraiment ce matin c'est
quelqu'un de calme d'assez réservé oui
on véritablement ce n'est pas son style
et je vais pas veux pas parler pour lui
mais je le connais assez bien et je suis
très content de ce qui lui arrive et
mais il est illettré c'est un très bon
joueur et on en reparlera dans trois
semaines trois semaines d'accord bon ben
ya là y'a un truc est pas un flop c'est
l'émission de guy bedos a tout à l'heure
sur canal avec florence belkacem vous
l'avez vu j'aime bien qu'il vaut deux
mois pour moi c'est ça aussi le dit lui
même beaucoup d'égoïsme 1-1 ouais je
voulais juste 10 1 qui disons que contre
mon intelligence systématiquement presse
interposée puisse comme souvent jeune et
je les aime beaucoup
merci je vois le sisqa d'or mais c'était
génial voilà alors maintenant passe au
jeu de la vraie vérité c'est à dire que
on va vraiment tout se dire la vérité
ici sur ce plateau
ça va être une expérience assez
étonnante qui n'a jamais été tenté la
télévision alors évidemment ça s'appelle
personne ne manque
il faut éviter oui et pour présenter ce
jeu de la vérité ce jeu de la vraie
vérité nous allons accueillir celui qui
à la télévision il ya quelques années
avait inventé le jeu de la vérité
patrick savatier
[Applaudissements]
donc vous connaissez reconnaissez linda
hardy
j'ai vu à au cinéma et à la télé de la
télévision c'est vous qui êtes allé voir
rectoverso voilà non mais tu est ici
c'est sympa parce qu'en fait le film
avec trois cent mille entrées pas brillé
aux anglais sam et si en plus
malheureusement j'étais pas avec un
spectateurs payants je développe
projection comme faut dire quand même
les choses il a été dans le film était
vraiment excellente c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça qu'elle était assise ici ce soir
ce film n'a pas été complètement
cimenterie l'objet d'une question
d'ailleurs sans doute
jamel debbouze que celle raid vous
connaissez c'est des gens que vous
recevez sûr vous avez reçues sur tmc
dans votre émission
axel oui on a passé une heure et demi
ensemble windsor et puis aller à cette
émission est prêt je l'avais cette
semaine c'est l'une des meilleures
émissions que j'ai fait moi aussi moi
aussi moi aussi j'ai regardé la cassette
le week-end suivant les cheveux ça dure
60 minutes en cinq minutes sans minutes
et moi aussi ce que tu veux et les
questions sont super intéressant alors
jeté sur elle et salut oui on est très
contents ou c'est là alors le jeu de la
vérité à l'époque à la télévision ça a
été un événement considérable on se
souvient tous de coluche assis sur un
sur une chaise haute géante
répondant en direct aux questions des
téléspectateurs qu'est ce qu'il ya comme
autres moments comme ça d'abord il ya eu
le premier de long aujourd'hui 1985 de
l'ong qui n'avait donné son accord
environ huit mois avant en disant tu
viens me chercher c'était à l'aéroport
ils venaient de genève et il m'a dit tu
viens me chercher le 10 janvier le rouge
de fret en émission et le 11 il a fait
l'émission en direct et c'est vrai que
c'est lui qui a déclenché en réalité
merci monsieur delon parce que c'est lui
qui a déclenché la notoriété du jeu de
la vérité
il ya eu gainsbourg ouais et puis il ya
eu évidemment on peut pas ne pas en
parler chantal goya ia de nature il est
sa carrière
pendant qu'ils croient qu'ils ont
vraiment raconter la vérité est que je
vais te dire que la plupart du temps
avant l'émission il me demandait de ne
pas laisser passer telle ou telle
question
pas tous mais certains parce que ça les
touche est trop près et j'ai toujours
respecté
respectez ça c'est parce que je pense
que quand on invite quelqu'un faudra
respecter avant tout et donc c'est sûr
que il ya même eu des gens donc je ne
vais pas citer leurs noms mais qui n'ont
pas voulu le faire parce que ils avaient
peur les questions oui en tous les cas
il fallait une sacrée force de
conviction pour convaincre des grands
artistes comme cela de venir à la télé
de s'asseoir en direct et d'avoir des
gens qui leur pose le public qui leur
pose toutes les questions
moi mon sens aucun projet ouais en gros
succès pour le faire il ya ka chantal
goya que ça pas moi j'ai pas compris
chantal biya parce que quand on a fait
les répétitions l'après midi ça se
passait bien je crois que c'est le soir
qu'elle a des gens qu'elle a prêté des
plans un péter les plombs en direct
alors là on va faire le jeu de la vraie
vérité donc il n'est pas du tout le
concept de patrick mais je voulais que
patrick soit là parce que dans le genre
en vérité c'était très fort alors vous
connaissez le jeu 1 et 3 heures du matin
on avec des copains un peu torché et
puis on se dit voilà on va maintenant on
va se dire les choses il faut pas
toujours être torche et comme vous dites
pourquoi se dire les choses
bah disons que ça peut aider d'être un
petit peu quand même posé une question
au préalable
est ce que la vérité est elle toujours
bonne à dire est ce que est ce qu'il
faut toujours cela dit on a tout essayé
c'est ma première question je peux la
pause m 6 millions balancy alors deux
questions
e
restait alors à travers ce que la vérité
tout est elle toujours bonne à dire que
ce que vous avez toujours dit votre
vérité la vérité
je pense qu'il ya des vérités qui ne
sont pas bonnes à dire parce que la
personne qui est en face de vous ne peut
pas la supporter dans certains cas la
délicatesse l'amour la charité veux que
vous passiez un acte de restriction ça
c'est normal je crois que dans une vie
de couteau dans une vie de groupe ou
dans une vie publique où tu as vu vie
privée on a tous ressenti ça c'est un
geste de délicatesse alors pu me poser
des questions à tout le monde c'est le
principe
voilà alors djamel pourrais me poser une
question je répondrais la vérité mais
demande à linda vous pareil voilà à dire
n'importe quelle question
question et les gens diront la vérité
pourquoi tu détestes guy bedos
ouais non c'est vrai je pense que je
sais même plus pourquoi je les teste dis
moi pourquoi
non franchement je sais pas je sais
pourquoi moi pour me dire ou alors parce
que je sais pas ils avaient été
apparemment refusé toutes ces
invitations
oui bien sûr mais ça mais au départ
pourquoi je sais pas c'est vrai tu sais
pas l'enfant je parle des tests pour
rien parce qu'ils m'aiment pas voilà
parce que dans la vie il ya des gens qui
vous aiment pas là vous les aimez pas
attendre à tuer moi c'est intelligent
non voilà j'aime bien les primes bonne
question
alors quand une histoire dans laquelle
sont pourtant jamais chez orange m
est-ce que ça il est venu voir votre
spectacle
oui vous l'avez vu vous féliciter oui
non paye jamais réussi je te jure il
n'est pas venu me féliciter vous savez
pas accepter qu'ils viennent de rentrer
dans votre loge quoi oui oui vous n'avez
pas que c'était 40 dans votre moi j'ai
ma fierté que smaïn oui je te jour là
alors je vais dire je te dire ce qui
s'est passé est véritablement un
quiproquo sincèrement arrive oui
vraiment à quoi un quiproquo cherche
dans le dictionnaire à cul voilà maître
rené flamand non c'est pas mal an qui
font très bien
voilà qui promet l'entendent non
vraiment mais alors jamais helvétique et
les vieux voir le spectacle est en fait
je l'avais en face de moi et non oui ils
rigolent ils ne paient pas parce que y
il analysé le spectacle et riri jamais
je ne savais pas où j'allais pas que je
m'éclate quand j allais vrai spectacle
il ne riez pas c'est vous m oui mais je
sais j'ai trouvé le nom de vos premier
one man show c'est vrai oui c'est vrai
oui j'ai beaucoup de respect pour son
travail pour lui aucun lien aucun
problème est toujours le même but en
plus j en connais aucune animosité
simplement quand il est vivement mon
spectacle parce que moi je regarde tout
le monde quand je joue je regarde les
gens dans les yeux et lui il est en
phase ii - iriepa est comme ça mais que
j'aime bien je me disais mais pourquoi
il rit pas à sa page et du spectacle
comme ça ok non mais moi je pense qu'on
peut dire quand il est volontiers dans
la loge il pas il abrite être dans la
bonne loges
bachand meilhan poser une question qui
vous voulez et le titre made in comment
l éphémère gens mis en jeu posé des
questions à bout mais un mois ali hadj
ahmed
allez-y quand vous préparez une émission
comme ça oui
choisissez commun en fait les
participants
ben je voulais le premier d'abord je les
choisis pas tout seul j'ai choisi et
catherine barma et ailleurs moi aussi on
en parle on en parle tout le monde en
parle
et finalement c'est vrai que l'on fait
un petit peu le principe c'est un peu
comme un dîner en ville on essaye de
mettre autour de la table des gens qui
n'ont pas grand chose à faire ensemble
et voilà donc poésie de créer dé créer
des mélanges de genre comme un dîner en
ville il ya toujours un archevêque une
[ __ ] je vais vous pensez qu'on aurait pu
s'inviter des uns des autres mais juste
patrick tata pas des boules de paille
sur france 2 ni sur tf1 ah ouais si je
veux que je parle pour toi je te piste à
se questionner j'aimerais bien venir
mais pourquoi tu reviens pas mais moi
moi moi je serai à pexiora nous ferons
avec
c'est pas moi qui choisis un regard ce
jeu est super content maintenant est en
train de retard au tableau d'affichage à
fermer des portes autoroute à barrer le
passage
oui ça c'est sûr on t'a dit non tu le
feras plus télé chez nous parce que ma
ouais enfin en réalité on ne m'a jamais
vraiment demandé qu'on m'a ça arrange
pas mal de gens que je n'y sois pas mais
voilà c'est une pièce qui merci d'avoir
répondu avec cette franchise je peux
dire en ce qui me concerne que je ne
comprends pas pourquoi patrick sabatier
aujourd'hui n'est pas sur une chaîne
jour j'ai peint sur un budget de cirer
les pompes mais je comprends pas moi non
plus c'est bon
m
le plaisir je fais des tournantes et que
patrick christine je veux vous poser une
question sur l'une des bergers du seuil
imposé à christine voilà comment tu
t'entends avec marie josé pérec pas
spécialement bien ce n'est pas du tout
mais alors c'est excuse moi c'est une
bonne question une très bonne réponse
excusez moi je parle à ta place mais je
sais pas ce que je pense qu'à chaque
fois sur je pense que vous l'avez
remarqué mais est dans une situation il
ya toujours un créneau où il ya deux
personnes qui sont assimilés il ya eu
une eau et fignon il ya eu de longs
belmondo il ya eu un moment donné
drucker et moi jamais avoué pacino
christine et marie josée et c'est sûr
que quand si on parle nettement on ne
peut pas vraiment aimer l'autre on a un
peu en rivalité et en plus la presse
nous même rivalité les années sont pas
nécessairement quoi pas nécessairement
je veux dire qu'un bon marie jo je n'ai
pas comme un concurrent direct a fait du
400 mètres moi je fais du sprint aux
cours mais il ya toujours eu ce problème
entre nous moi je peux avoir des copines
qui font du 100 m je veux dire sur la
piste bon là ce moment là on est plus
copine c'est pas con et rivas et moi je
pense qu'on peut faire la part des
choses je peux dire j'aurais pu être
copine avec elle sans pour autant qu'ils
aient enfin cette animosité contre n'ont
cessé de la différence qu'apporte entre
guillemets un peu à la france en allant
s'entraîner à los angeles trop extrêmes
le manque de respect non pas du tout
c'est son choix
elle a envie de s'entraîner aux états
unis voilà désolé pour vous et normal
qu'elle s'entraîne à los angeles c'est
ma façon plus belles là bas les qua non
c'est vrai que c'est une femme
est ce qu'il y ait encore des questions
que vous avez envie de vous poser les
uns les autres
profitez-en parce que j'en ai jamais
s'il veut redevenir hypocrite n'a pas la
grosse tête avec tout ce qui t'arrive
parce que tu es quand même assez jeune
tu vas quand même un bon succès auprès
auprès de tout le monde je me brosse tu
être honnête je l'assumé pleinement
c'est quelque chose que je dis bien tous
les matins sous le nom sa salle à manger
parce que j'avais pas avoir la grosse
tête c'est quoi ces jeux-là raconté
moquette voilà voilà
j'ai rêvé que bon oui on a réussi donc
on considère que les autres sont
inférieurs on y traite pas de la même
façon ce jour monde sait ça sincèrement
pour l'instant non mais sachez une chose
et je préviens tous mes proches que si
par malheur je vais tourner un jour aux
states à los angeles où un le loc
c'est la merde pour vous parce que là je
vais la prendre et solitude
[Applaudissements]
merci à tous avec nous on peut rallumer
les lumières
vous devez résider roule aussi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
cela fait quelque sorte ce que je ne
trouve pas ce qu'en dit m'a dit
tellement moins temps de sommeil
tu couches dans tous les sens et cela
fait trente fois je peux partir les
dessins du plus fort c'est en vain et
les montants n'y changeait rien que ma
montée beauchamp car mojtaba la soirée
[Musique]
la soirée quant à moi je voulais pas les
mamours mois
[Musique]
je vous laisse pas les mois
jusqu'en
j'ai fait le ventirad
vincent schricke
je touche je prenne pourtant ce coût sur
moi sur mon canton
[Musique]
certes ça j'ai pour me fatiguer moi je
tente toujours pas te tuerais chip
je sais en vendent
quand il l'aimé
mais je ne sais rien
dire vers toi car moi je tends la soirée
[Musique]
non
la soirée pas optimaux je voulais pas
les mamours
et
maman
hamon
moore
je voulais parler mamour
[Musique]
n'est ce pas
richaud
[Musique]
tu vois je voulais juste
tu mens
[Musique]
chaque dimanche
ces mamans
malema
[Musique]
laisse moi te fais pas les mains
jusqu'au jour
axelrod
je voulais faire des mamours faire des
mamours merci beaucoup merci d'ailleurs
un chercheur kalfon c'est un bon moment
si l'image pouvait devenir rose
voilà convives voilà est-ce qu'on peut
mettre le jingle voilà et l'image rôle
et quand tombera alors j'ai décidé jeudi
jeu là j'ai décidé de me faire plaisir
voilà d'invités mais que les gens que
j'aime et de me faire plaisir c'est
normal non voilà notre ami djamel donc
et au bataclan à partir du 15 septembre
évidemment tous y aller 3 novembre le 3
novembre vous êtes au zénith
axel c'est ça c'est le problème en vo et
ninon voilà il faut tous y aller aussi
voilà donc l'émission est terminée on va
faire un petit bilan un an mais c'est
bien ce genre qui disent ah merci
perfectible mais pas malheur ouais elle
est pas mal non
[Applaudissements]
jean de tirer les leçons de cette
émission s'est séparé un petit bilan
jamel pour ma part cette émission
faisait passer un petit peu à la halle à
l'arc en ciel parce que l'arc en ciel
c'est beau c'est sympa ça fait rêver
autour de cette table avec des gens
sympas
bon on avait le sourire du début jusqu'à
la fin ouais personne c'est répartir les
personnes est parti en vrille
ouais même si à un moment donné charles
millon un petit bilan de la première
émission mais moi personnellement j'ai
un peu trop parlé non si on n'a pas
toujours très bien compris mais vous
avez envie dames est revenue à 100
millions est ce que vous êtes content
d'avoir rencontré djamel très content
bien c'est maintenant qu'on a dit qu'il
était quelqu'un de bien et qu'il était
formidable elle avait un beau sourire ça
va maintenant
ben disons que ça va m'aider à faire la
deuxième voilà c'était tout le monde en
parle mais s'il me navre si thierry en
cours voilà bah kotecha aux adieux à ses
vous c'est vous qui voyez si ses adieux
tant pis et si c'est charles rendez vous
la semaine prochaine et à demain si vous
le voulez bien merci
[Musique]
tu souris
ce matin
[Musique]
au réveil
teymour je me sens si bien que ce soit
ne rien lâcher
et belle
veillée
je mets
des toits
je ne pense pas
viens à tel point que je voulais les
sous
kimmons 4 m e
l'appartement
[Musique]
on rappelé
quelques chiffres
[Musique]
oui
non
je me sens
et 1